some eternally useful lessons about
exercising trauma and self-actualization
lie just below the surface of the Pope's
Exorcist in the Pope's Exorcist father
gabrielli amort played by Russell Crowe
heads to Spain to help a young boy named
Henry who is possessed after moving with
his mother and sister into an abandoned
Abbey while performing an exorcism on
Henry father amort becomes possessed
himself after the Vasquez family is
safely out of the house and demon-free
he goes into the catacombs Beneath The
Abbey after a battle with the help of
his colleague father Esquibel he forces
the demon back into hell but father
amort isn't the same after this whole
ordeal viewers learn that he is
remorseful for his role in a young
girl's death by Suicide but it isn't
until the demon makes him relive that
event that he confesses to God again
it's a reminder that even if we
initially confess our mistakes it
sometimes takes another Catalyst for the
message to sink in otherwise father
amort's life may have continued in a
different direction he might have
continued to overlook certain places
where he was needed by acting pridefully
instead he ends up helping the church
research other locations that may have
the same type of demonic presence
is courage to
show before father amort's arrival
father eskibel shows up as Henry's
condition rapidly declines however he's
the wrong priest according to the demon
over the course of the movie we learned
that father Esquibel had indiscretions
and chose the priesthood over the woman
he loved he is a timid individual who
grows into his role as a man of Faith
under father amort's tutelage while
father Esquibel struggles to resist to
the taunts and temptations of the demon
he ultimately overcomes his fears and
helps father amort survive his
possession the lesson here is that we
are only as great at something as we
allow ourselves to be father Esquibel
could have allowed his weaknesses to
prevent him from completing the exorcism
instead he finds strength in what he
doesn't know and allows that to fuel him
on his chosen path he also demonstrates
that sometimes we are the only ones
holding ourselves back father amort
believed in Father eskibel even when he
had doubts about himself while it took a
traumatic experience for him to reach
his full potential it is an important
realization for him to have especially
considering what he chose to give give
up when he joined the church
The Vasquez family consisting of Mom
Julia teenage daughter Amy and tween son
Henry moved to Spain after the death of
Julia's husband The Abbey had been in
his family and they inherited it upon
his death they're in a tight financial
bind so they move into the Abbey with
the plan to fix it up and sell it after
Henry's possession and exorcism
audiences are told that they move back
to the United States and that Henry
makes a complete recovery viewers don't
actually see the vasquezas in that
better place as the Pope's Exorcist
doesn't feel the need to devote screen
time to their happy ending despite being
the initial victims of the demon and
being indirectly responsible for his
return to the surface World they aren't
the focus of the story some things don't
necessarily need to be spelled out to
audiences and this is one of those cases
this can be a surprising Rarity in
cinema as producers can be worried that
viewers won't be able to keep up with
the narrative but this ending offers a
welcome change from that habit I'm here
to help Julia when the vasquez's move
into the San Sebastian Abbey it is run
down and they work to restore it while
maintaining the original architectural
features but considering what happens
over the course of the film it isn't
exactly in the best condition when the
priests leave the church effectively
raids the property rescuing the
documents that the priests find in the
catacombs below they also reconsecrate
the land in an effort to keep the demon
back in Hell the state of the property
is symbolic of both the film's ending
and where the two priests end up after
the exorcisms like the Abbey the priests
made it to the other side alive even
though there was some damage inflicted
along the way for the priests this comes
in the form of both emotional and
physical distress but for the Abbey it
was only physical damage but also like
the priests The Abbey still stands tall
despite the huge flames of gas and a
demon literally trying to take over the
church it doesn't crumble under that
pressure and neither do fathers amort
and eskibel sometimes we have to
experience pain to grow as people
similarly The Abbey will grow
metaphorically with the church's
intervention and the reconsecration even
though it won't be used as an Abbey
again it has served an important purpose
that will positively impact the church
for years to come
described as the king of Hell by father
immort as medius is the demon present
within the San Sebastian Abbey unlike
demons from other exorcism films as
medius is a powerful entity that
completely changes the course of history
in the film fathers amort and eskibel
seem to successfully send the demon back
to hell in the Final Act and the
reconsecration of the land should
provide an additional barrier to keep
him from returning anytime soon sealing
asmodeus back into hell is an excellent
representation of something we all do in
our lives compartmentalization when we
experience emotions we aren't prepared
to deal with we section them off in our
mind until we're ready to deal with them
just like how Henry became mute after
his father's death and that's
effectively what the priests are doing
as well the church isn't prepared to
deal with a demon this powerful so he's
instead walled off until they have time
to prepare however they do take the time
to go through the documents they gather
from The Abbey sometimes we need to do
some work before we can approach intense
emotions especially those rooted in
trauma even if it will take a long time
like the priest's Quest to find the 100
other locations that contain similar
portals to hell it's usually worth it I
call it
evil there are several factors that lead
to Henry's possession the construction
of the Abbey is one of them as it
creates an opening in the physical
barrier keeping the demon at Bay but
Henry's personal pain also leaves him
particularly vulnerable he was in the
car when his father died tragically and
violently and that trauma understandably
had a significant impact on him when we
meet him at the beginning of the movie
he hasn't spoken for an entire year he's
still hurting and moving to an
unfamiliar place isn't helping while
this is a particularly drastic case it's
important to remember that sometimes
while trying to process pain we actually
make ourselves more vulnerable we can
become so focused on trying to work
through something that it can blind us
to other situations that can also hurt
us in Henry's case this includes an
opening in his soul for a demon a Latin
phrase that translates to our sins will
seek us out is repeated throughout the
film because of its use in the documents
that discuss the history of the Abbey
this phrase reminds us that someone will
take advantage of our weaknesses if we
let them just as the demon takes
advantage of Father amort's trauma and
him memories pain while Henry's trauma
is relatively fresh father amorts has
been around for much longer we see
flashbacks to his time at War as he
watches his friends killed by German
soldiers and we also see the young woman
Rosaria jump to her death in front of
him both incidents took place many years
earlier but both still nonetheless weigh
on him heavily trauma doesn't
automatically go away after a certain
amount of time even many years later we
can still feel intense emotions seeing
that depicted on screen is an important
reminder of that for all audiences but
for men in particular whose mental
health has not always been prioritized
in popular culture father amort almost
looks ashamed that these events still
weigh on him and he considers it a
weakness that they can still be used
against him by the demons but he
shouldn't be there isn't a linear path
to healing and that is shown in how
Henry copes with his father's passing
and how father amort remembers his time
at War you've been
as the priests look into the history of
the San Sebastian Abbey they discovered
that the last time as medius walked into
the human world it was in the body of an
important priest this allowed the demon
to infiltrate the church ultimately
leading to the Spanish Inquisition
what's worse is that the church knew
that this happened and handled it by
Walling the possessed priest away Under
The Abbey and redacting all of the
information from their records anyone
can cover something up if they are
ashamed of it the church covered up what
happened at the Abbey because they were
ashamed of the role they had in one of
the darkest chapters in religious
history they knew that what happened was
wrong but they still chose to prevent
the public from learning about it as it
would discredit the church if people
knew all the details but the Pope's
Exorcist makes sure to let us know that
even when you try to keep something a
secret it will always come to light
eventually in the case of the church it
takes hundreds of years but the truth
still eventually comes out their secrets
are revealed because the demon is
uncaged which leads to more possessions
if the church had been forthcoming about
the history of the Abbey the possessions
of Henry and father amort have possibly
been prevented
ultimately the Pope's Exorcist makes it
clear that our metaphorical demons will
come back to haunt us for father amort
this involves guilt over traumatic
memories being used against him by an
actual demon for the church it involves
that demon coming out of the Abbey in
which they can find it and for father
eskibel it's a matter of his
indiscretions in previous relationships
but the movie also reminds us that we
don't have to let those demons take over
our life both priests fight against what
asmodeus presents to them and don't
allow themselves to become distracted
from the task at hand even though father
amort does become possessed he
ultimately refuses to be haunted by the
past any further while it may not seem
like it at first the Pope's Exorcist can
be interpreted as a powerful message
about how to handle past trauma the
guilt over our past actions that can
threaten to consume Us and how we can
conquer those demons as we work through
our pain over time that is the journey
father amort goes through over the
course of the film as he performs the
exorcisms my faith
does not require defense
the Pope's Exorcist is based on two
books by the real father Gabriella amort
in his writings he describes his
experience as an exorcist with the Roman
Catholic church so there's certainly
potential to continue father remort's
story on screen the Pope's Exorcist
takes place in 1987 just a single year
into amort's tenure there are plenty of
other episodes that can be told about
his life and his work as he conducted
thousands of exorcisms over the course
of his time with the church the two
books that the film is based on and
Exorcist tells his story and an exorcist
more stories surely include other cases
and information that could be adapted
into sequels any potential follow-up
could also show father amort's Journey
as one of the founders of the
International Association of exorcists
in 1990. exorcisms are still contested
in the public eye and following the
priest's journey of creating an
organization for exorcists could provide
a new angle in a genre that can
sometimes struggle to be original